foreign
let's go to Ashley in Pittsburgh hey
Ashley what's up
hi thanks for taking my call how are you
I'm fantastic how are you
good all right so what's up
I have quite the Dizzy for you so I was
watching your show and I was watching
your show and I have recently been
having
an issue with my mother-in-law and I can
say it's recent but it actually has been
going on for quite some time so we my
husband and I just welcomed a daughter
and she's five weeks old congratulations
thank you and whenever we go to
um visit family we don't go to visit my
mother-in-law and my father-in-law and
that's due to I mean just to get right
into it
um my mother-in-law she has been
suffering from anxiety and depression
evidently for like 25 years and and the
time that I've been in the family like
seven years later I've really watched it
escalate and
it's really tough and I'm
this is a tough situation for the whole
family because it's one of those things
that nobody is
nobody's been able to put their thumb on
why we can't
um why we can't help some of these some
of the things that she's been
um that have been affecting the rest of
us so really what my question is is we
we don't go over to visit because her
house is absolutely filthy and my
father-in-law he doesn't he's I think
that he's just exhausted and there's
nothing that he's been able to do to
um to get a hold of it or try to better
the situation and she also smokes in the
home and I just had an appointment for
my daughter like a week ago and the
doctor asked does she is she exposed to
secondhand smoke and I said no but
that's because we don't go over to visit
but this whole Myriad of issues has
driven a little bit of a wedge between
me and my mother-in-law because I just
won't take her over to their house
instead
let's reframe that okay
is that cool okay I want to reframe this
whole conversation
um
the rift in in the family
is not because of your mother-in-law
the rift in your family is because your
family and probably your husband's
family
um is trying to solve problems that's
the person with the challenges is not
asking them to solve and really has no
interest in changing
and so what's happening is a whole bunch
of people are making themselves crazy
trying to fix a problem that the person
who's experiencing it doesn't want fixed
I called because I was like man I've
pulled out all the stops I've done
everything I can do there's no stop
here's the one thing you haven't done
the only thing that that matters here
and that is look that sweet little baby
girl in the eye and say I've got one job
and that's to the best of my ability to
keep you safe
not keep you yeah infinitely protected
from scraping your little knee and
getting in trouble and getting dumped
that's life
but I'm talking about from things that
are going to harm you
and sending your kid to somebody who's
not well
in a home full of smoke
in a home that you've described as
unsanitary is not safe
yeah and so
because your mother-in-law is either
unable to or is not interested in
doing this hard hard hard stuff she
would need to do to get well
she by proxy is choosing to not see that
little girl
it's as simple as that
and to my colleagues who would say well
she can't make that choice because she's
struggling with X Y and Z that's fine
too I'm this isn't a blaming
conversation this is just laying out the
facts
whether she's choosing to not get well I
don't think anybody's choosing to be
anxious I don't think anybody chooses to
be a hoarder or a living filth I don't
think that's a choice I think I'm
choosing to not get well right that's a
byproduct or they can't make that choice
and it just is either way I'm not
putting my kid in that situation
right okay so that's where I struggle
because I want to help and I've done
everything I can would you recommend any
I would recommend that you detox I can
read about nope I would detox you got a
detox from being a people pleaser
and you have to detox from being I'm
freaking Ashley from Pittsburgh and I'm
in control of everything no you're not
so should detox from all right I'm in
control of everything in my own little
world because you just had a baby and
you are not and that's gonna make you
mad and not mad like angry but mad
insane
yeah because you could control it all
until baby came and then you have those
moments that you realize some you think
back to some of the dates you've been on
and you think back to some of the things
that people told you on the school bus
and there's that moment that all new
parents have I have them and by the way
it's not just new parents it's when our
kids go to different stages like when my
kid went to middle school I thought back
to the things I was a part of and things
that happened to me in middle school and
I got sick to my stomach like I got like
I got literally ill
I thought of the things I said to
little kids when I was in elementary
school when I was in Middle School I was
mean
and I have a seven-year-old daughter and
it makes me ill like to my stomach to
know that there's gonna be people like
me around her
and get choked up saying if I'm not
careful
and this is the part where love gets
really scary
and most of us when things get scary we
tighten our grip around the wheel
and it doesn't help and anything
sometimes the greatest gift is to loosen
our grip on that wheel that makes sense
yeah so don't get your esteem and don't
get your value and don't take your angst
out on trying to fix your mother-in-law
she has not invited you into that
conversation she hasn't asked for your
help she doesn't want to be less anxious
she doesn't want to whatever but she has
asked for my help okay and I've done
everything I can and that's where I'm
I and I feel like I've done I've done
reading and yeah I've this is about
other people with this and at the risk
of sounding ignorant towards anxiety and
depression I don't experience it but I
this she's evidently she's been battling
this and has been to so many doctors and
has been on countless medications which
scares me because when you're switching
medications constantly that can't be
good for her brain
and I think to the future and I'm like
what yeah yeah what I mean but again but
then it goes back to what you said with
you can't control that she doesn't want
to get better right and so here's the
deal she might say the words I want your
help
and if you've listened to this show for
more than a couple of episodes I always
probably say it too much behavior is a
language
so I can tell my wife I want to be a
better husband I want to be a better
husband and then I never help with the
dishes I don't want to be a better
husband no matter what I'm saying
because my actions are speaking very
loudly
and I can say I don't want to be
depressed I don't want to be anxious
anymore I'm tired of feeling anxious all
the time and my actions say well I'm not
going to call a counselor
I'm not going to start hanging out with
people and get some community in my life
I'm not going to start eating well and
taking care of my body I'm not gonna do
that
well behavior is a language
I'm gonna write that down that's some
good stuff but but here's the deal
um don't go to war with it open your
hands up
it just it's an is
yeah and know this that when I I
I've got two competing rules and they
often intersect and they don't know the
two rules of life
um or two of many rules of life I have
number one is I don't speak to just have
said something that's our instagrammy
world like people are always asking why
didn't you comment on this and why don't
you comment on that because I don't have
anything to add to the noise
and they just people people don't want
to know what I have to think about
things they just want to see if I'm on
their team about a thing so that's
number one I only speak if I can
actually be heard
the second thing is
um
I don't let
I I I let me say it this way it's cruel
to put up boundaries and not let people
know that there's a boundary there
and they're just running in in and also
They smash into something they didn't
know was there
and I get that with your mother-in-law
she may not be able to hear it if you
sit down and say I love you so much and
I'm so grateful for you I'm not
comfortable nothing to do with her I'm
not comfortable bringing my kid into a
house where somebody smokes inside
I'm not comfortable bringing my kid into
this house
because as we've talked about it's
really unsanitary
I'll be with you if you ask for my help
you want to clean the sucker up and all
that I'm all in but right now I'm making
this choice
am I a bad person if I've thrown in the
towel on trying to help in multiple ways
because I've been there to help clean no
and no because I'm just exhausted no
you're not a bad person like the rest of
the family and that's where I have a
hard time like man she's 50. and is this
just how life's gonna be and we're just
gonna
own reality well I guess we are just
choose reality
it is what is there it is what it is I
choose reality and I mean I wouldn't do
this show if I didn't believe deeply
that
man I just seen people come back from
the brink in all all different ages all
different situations all different like
from the wildest trauma to
you know 60 and 70 year old saying I'm
just gonna be different now
um and they just choose a different pest
so I'm in this for the Long Haul I I I I
don't believe in quote unquote giving up
on somebody I also
believe in living in reality
so you've been there a bunch you've
tried to clean up a bunch it has not
worked great
I'm gonna stop expending energy all the
time trying to solve that problem and
quite frankly that exhaustion you feel
is probably you on the treadmill
you're not going anywhere it's running
really hard
if there comes a moment when she says
I'm ready finally I'm ready ready
seeing a counselor I'm meeting with my
doctor to get some stability here
I want to start doing regular lunches or
breakfast or whatever once a week with
so and so and fill in the blank here
we're gonna we're gonna set up a pattern
we're gonna set up a life
um you're gonna find you have a lot more
energy because you haven't been just
sprinting and sprinting and sprinting
and getting nowhere right but no don't
ever apologize especially as a mom of a
five week old or five month old
for not having energy
you get a moment you get a moment and
particularly do not apologize for your
boundaries it's a conversation for you
and
your spouse to sit down and say okay uh
what boundaries do we want to have for
this little one
and we have to be on the same page as we
move forward
we're gonna be in this together
congratulations on having a little baby
I wish it was different I know that's
not how you envisioned this thing going
I know that
I'm sorry
and the only thing you can handle
is what comes next only you can deal
with is what comes next
can't wait to see what happens